[Music]
120 light years away from us there's an
exoplanet that can potentially host
life it's called
k218b and it's a world you'd want to
visit
k218b isn't exactly like Earth it's more
like a super Earth yeah it's 2.6 times
larger and almost nine times more
massive than our
planet scientists think it could be a
hyen exoplanet which is just a fancy way
of saying that it likely has a
hydrogen-rich atmosphere and is covered
in liquid ocean that means that
k218b could be home to alien
life only it would take a really long
time to get there if you were hurdling
toward this space Rock from Earth you'd
reach your destination in about 1.3
million years yeah you heard right
million k218b has a lot of methane and
carbon dioxide in its atmosphere that's
not exactly breathable air so you'd
still need a space suit to walk on this
world and I wouldn't be too hyped up
about its ocean either if an exoplanet
has liquid on it it doesn't mean that
the liquid is water
it could be methane or ammonia even acid
like even in our own solar system
There's a Moon covered in liquid Lakes
but these are methane and ethane lakes
and I wouldn't recommend swimming
there k218b could have a pretty mild
temperature for an exoplanet that is at
Min -100° C you'd find this world
incredibly cold
now the most exciting thing we found out
about this world is that it could have
traces of dimethyl
sulfide woot woot well on Earth this
molecule can only be produced by living
things and that means
k218b could be home to alien life now it
doesn't mean that this life would be
intelligent it could be aquatic or
microbial maybe even complex life if the
conditions for it are just right we
won't know for sure unless we travel to
explore this Interstellar
world now how do we know all this well
we had the James web Space Telescope
look at this distant world and take
detailed measurements of its atmosphere
most of the exoplanets have been
discovered using What's called the
transit method it's when a planet passes
in front of its star and blocks its
Starlight that's when scientists study
the wavelengths around the planets and
some of those wavelengths can tell us
what kind of atmosphere those distant
planets
have the problem is exoplanets are
really far away trying to figure out
what their surfaces are like just by
peering through even our most powerful
telescopes is not easy some scientists
will argue that k218b isn't a super
Earth at all but a mini
Neptune and that's a bummer because as
you know Neptune is an ice Giant and if
k218b is also an ice giant then the
chances for alien life on this planet
don't look so
good now you don't have a million years
to travel to this world to discover it
for yourself so maybe we should look at
a world that's a lot closer to
earth like Proxima
centor Proxima Cent Tor is the closest
star we've discovered only 4.2 light
years away from Earth it's part of the
alpha centory star system with not two
but three stars orbiting each
other the exoplanet Proxima centor B
orbits only one of these stars but
you'll still see the other two stars as
bright dots in the
sky this exoplanet is slightly larger
than Earth and revolves uncomfortably
close to its host star luckily that star
is a red dwarf and that's much cooler
and smaller than our
sun which is good news because that
means this planet isn't getting toasted
like
Mercury scientists estimate Proxima
centor B has an average temperature of
about - 39°
c that's pretty comfortable as far as
alien worlds go the bad news is that we
still don't know much about the
exoplanet's gravity or atmosphere it
might be our best candidate to set up an
Interstellar base but it also could have
a harsh environment unsuitable for
Humanity's future home it might even
have an ocean of acid or something
deadly like
that the only way to find out is to
travel there and if Proxima centor B
doesn't work out well don't worry there
are plenty of potentially habitable
worlds out there like this
one Ross 128b is 11 light years from
Earth it's the second closest
potentially habitable World scientists
have discovered and it's more promising
than proximus and Tory B the thing is
they both orbit red dwarf stars only
Proxima be's host star is a lot more
active and violent it occasionally
erupts and bathes Proxima be in r
radiation Ross 128 B's star is nice and
quiet and even though this world orbits
20 times closer to its star than Earth
is to the sun it still lies in the
habitable zone because like I said red
dwarfs are way cooler than the Sun and
by Cooler I just mean
temperature this world could have a
balmy average temperature of 23° C
that's only slightly hotter than the
average temperature are here on Earth I
don't know about you but I could settle
there now we don't know enough about
this world to call it our new home it
likely has lots of harmful radiation
reaching its surface and its atmosphere
might not be breathable but hey that's
not much worse than Mars with efficient
life support systems in place we could
make it work besides this super Earth
might have its own life on it if Ross
one 28b did have alien life it could be
extremely different from what you might
imagine just think about making the
first contact with an alien
species what would that be
like I mean it could go very wrong too
for one we might not survive the trip to
any exoplanets even the nearest ones so
far we've discovered and confirmed over
5,000 alien world
63 of them are potentially habitable but
we just can't know for
sure most planets we've observed are
extremely
scary there's one exoplanet that
actually looks like Earth but this
beautiful blue world is not the kind of
place you could settle on if you tried
you'd be dead within
seconds but that's a story for
another what if
[Music]